team starting in uh two minutes as soon  as this one finishes and uh hans niemann  yeah look at that he's uh arrived early  and uh looking at the game  yeah he's arrived early he looks very  chill that hasn't even  uh but yeah unfortunately for levon  aronian duda is the one who's going to  be walking out of this hall with a win  um look at white's pawns those three  they're easily blockaded on the light  squares black's pawns though passports  on both sides of the board they're ready  to push and this pawn push is going to  overwhelm the white defenses  and uh now the white king will be tied  down  there's going to be a trick right the  king when it steps back the knight is  going to come to the c3 square very nice  ivanka and that will end the game we'll  explain that in a moment but duda does  take the win  it's over after a very long game young  christoph duda makes that comeback to  tie the match against the great lavon  aronian these two players will now have  10 min